[Musica]
ciao grazie siete davvero tanti e mi fa
molto piacere ma sono andrea ribaldone e
faccio il poco pensate che quando ero
giovane volevo fare la guida alpina o il
maestro di sci niente di più lontano
dalla professione che faccio oggi mi
impegnavo è negli allenamenti tantissimo
cioè io venivo dalla città arriva in
montagna mi impegnavo tantissimo
giornate e giornate di allenamenti di
sforzi però non riusciva ad arrivare non
riuscivo non ero il peggiore ma non ero
sicuramente uno dei migliori non
riuscivo a ad arrivare al punto e non
capivo il perché più tardi ho capito che
il problema era non mi immaginavo in
quel ruolo cioè la volontà da sola e
l'allenamento insieme
non bastavano ci andava anche la parte
di immaginazione ci andava anche la
parte di cuore questa è una cosa che
dico sempre ai miei ragazzi giovani che
si approcciano al mio mestiere
certo deve imparare a cucinare e quindi
ci va una parte proprio di lavoro
tecnico di allenamento continuo di
stress ma un'altra parte molto
importante è quella del cuore
dell'immaginazione cioè di pensarsi
cuochi di dire voglio essere davvero un
poco e di vedersi nel futuro in quella
in quella posizione qua mi vedete in
divisa quindi immaginare è più forte
della volontà immaginare è più forte
dell'allenamento l'amore il cuore vince
questa è la prima cosa altra davvero
importante è in italia tutti pensiamo
alla cucina come qualcosa di empirico
qualcosa che ci lega alla mamma la
famiglia alle nostre tradizioni e quindi
pensiamo che il passaggio sia semplice
la mamma insegna al figlio a mangiare
bene a cucinare o alla figlia che sia e
questo basta per fare ristoratore ma non
è così voi andreste ad esempio da un
cuoco
scusate da un un chirurgo non laureato a
farvi operare
penso proprio di no e quindi non capisco
perché vogliate andare a mangiare in
ristoranti dove ci sono cuochi
assolutamente che hanno studiato poco o
che conoscono poco la materia
la applicano in maniera empirica questo
grande errore ci va cultura e conoscenza
del cibo e della tecnica
altrimenti poi non si può innestare
quella che è la carica artistica e
arriviamo al terzo punto la parte
artistica che è una parte davvero
importante del mio lavoro è il momento
in cui io vado a pensare i piatti a
pensare i gusti
e come diceva nell'intervento del
professor rizzello la dissonanza dei
gusti perché questo è davvero molto
importante la dissonanza poi ne
parleremo ancora però nella cucina di
oggi è davvero molto molto importante e
quindi il lato artistico che entra in
cucina
forse noi non siamo dei veri e propri
artisti siamo più degli artigiani perché
l'artista compie un gesto unico che poi
rimane penso a un grande dipinto una
scultura carica artistica e poi è finito
noi invece ripetiamo il gesto due volte
al giorno due servizi al giorno quindi
forse siamo più degli artigiani però
nella fase del concepimento del piatto
lì c'è una parte artistica
anche questa è davvero importante e poi
veniamo a forse il punto cruciale di
tutto la leadership
perché un poco senza leadership è
impossibile perché in cucina non si sa
mai da soli se sempre accompagnati da
una brigata è una brigata è l'unica che
può far girare in maniera armonica un
ristorante un ristorante è come un
ingranaggio perfetto se un pezzo manca
se un pezzo non risponde non può più
funzionare
chiaramente ogni ragazzo ha esigenze
diverse qualità diverse modi di vedere
la vita diversi e a me piace questo
infatti io metto insieme brigate che
vengono da luoghi diversi spesso o
ragazzi giapponesi ragazzi che vengono
dal sud italia ragazzi che vengono
dall'america perché ognuno porta un
pezzo all'interno della costruzione del
ristorante il ristorante davvero
ingranaggio difficile se voi andate a
cena e tutto gira velocemente a volte
siete con gli amici non ve ne accorgete
neanche ma è davvero tutto molto
complicato perché in un'ora e mezza due
ore e l'ora e mezzo al massimo
bisogna servire almeno 40 commensali e
tutti nel giusto modo tutti nella giusta
maniera
questo cosa procura fortissima
adrenalina perché servire 40 commensali
a volte con piatti alla carta perché
magari immaginate un tavolo stasera
ristorante abbiamo un tavolo da 8 e
magari prenderanno tutti i piatti
diversi e quindi bisogna far uscire
insieme fatti bene caldi e tutti nello
stesso momento
questo comporta una forte adrenalina
grande scarica adrenalinica quindi il
cervello di ognuno di noi infatti io
dico che i cuochi sono effettivamente
sono alcolizzati e drogati
non tutti però in grande parte sì perché
hanno bisogno continuamente di scariche
adrenaliniche hanno bisogno
continuamente di sentire la tensione
però è quella tensione quella del
servizio che se poi un servizio fatto
bene diventa meravigliosa diventa una
tensione che alla fine si scioglie in un
servizio unico questo per i giovani è
importantissimo perché soprattutto i
nativi digitali ragazzi che adesso hanno
non so 15 17 18 20 anni ea salire anche
perché ormai tutti siamo su internet
siamo i social è tutto a volte è un like
non è una cosa molto veloce vede
un'immagine mi piace like è finito tutto
bello
mentre tutti i giorni avere degli orari
di lavoro pressanti e precisi e sapere
che a una determinata ora devo far
uscire piatti in maniera perfetta
questo vi mette a contatto con la realtà
in maniera molto forte a volte dura e
qualcuno non ce la fa ma in ogni caso se
supero quel momento quel gap che che mi
mi mi
mi fa sentire troppo stanco alla fine la
felicità di un servizio ben fatto è
qualcosa di unico anche per i ragazzi
giovani perché gli dà un messaggio di
realtà unico la parte adrenalinica e poi
tenete presente c'è questa parte
adrenalinica che è proprio del fuoco
mentre cucina ma poi ce n'è un'altra
ancora più potente e quella del contatto
con le persone che hanno mangiato
io spesso anzi sempre faccio uscire mi
cuochi in sala salutare perché vedere la
faccia contenta delle persone vedere che
hai fatto un buon lavoro vedere e avere
il contatto con gli altri felici è
qualcosa di unico
noi viviamo nel buono e nel bello cioè
l'altro giorno parlavo con un mio amico
dottore che mi diceva certo faccio un
bellissimo lavoro ma al tempo stesso
io vengo vengo a contatto con il dolore
delle persone e questo mi svuota
ogni giorno mi svuota mentre noi ci
carichiamo infatti per quello che
facciamo tante ore di lavoro perché ci
carichiamo ci carichiamo nei momenti
belli delle persone quindi non è il
denaro tanti pensano al primo ristorante
è apro il cassetto ci sono i soldi ma
prima di arrivare aprire quel cassetto
c'è ci va tanto tanto lavoro e
soprattutto se lo fate per quello non
fatelo perché è un sacrificio enorme
io dico sempre io non lavoro io sono il
mio lavoro che mia moglie è molto
contenta di questo come immagine però è
proprio così se pensate ai vostri figli
o anche voi stessi in un lavoro di
contatto col pubblico come la
ristorazione o lo fate con il cuore con
la passione o sennò non fatelo perché
davvero di grande sacrificio perché
quando noi lavoriamo gli altri si
divertono chiaramente ma è proprio in
questo divertimento che traiamo la
nostra forza è proprio in questo
divertimento che ci sentiamo meglio
un'altra cosa dico sempre anche i miei
ragazzi di imparare a sentirsi non mai
arrivati per fortuna nelle mie cucine
sono passati tanti tanti ragazzi di
alcuni di loro adesso una new york una
parigi 1 in un grande ristorante a
guarene e quindi
con orgoglio io dico sono hanno lavorato
con me sono stati sono stati a scuola un
po da me è la cosa che dico sempre non
sentitevi ma mai arrivati siate capaci
di essere sempre stupidi cioè di
stupirvi cioè di affrontare il vostro
lavoro e quindi ogni giorno in cucina
come se fosse sempre una novità
altrimenti vi annoierete le noi e rete
perché tanti pensano che venendo al
ristorante di trovare i piatti
rassicuranti il famoso con for food
oggi invece il ruolo di un ristorante
gastronomico è quello di avanguardia e
quindi di dissonanza come diceva
l'intervento del professor rizzello
dissonanza cioè è far sì che voi
arriviate a fine pasto dicendo ho
assaggiato cose che non ho mai mangiato
ho sentito sapori che non mi era mai
capitato di sentire
altrimenti che senso ha ripetere sempre
gli stessi gesti ogni giorno uguali
andare al ristorante non è andare a
nutrirsi andare al ristorante è vivere
un'esperienza del gusto che fa parte di
una sfera che è molto molto di più che
solo mangiare ma è una sfera cognitiva
che coinvolge tutti i sensi e che ti fa
sentire bene infatti io dico se uno esce
dal nostro ristorante ha mangiato bene a
una scarica a una scarica di di
endorfine di serotonina fortissima e
certo che ne parlerà e il suo cervello
di rane voglio ancora voglio tornare
perché così che funziona e quindi vi
prego quando andate al ristorante
soprattutto il ristorante gastronomico
in francia anche gli operai vanno al
ristorante gastronomico risparmio non
hanno e poi vanno perché vedono in quel
ristorante un posto dove fare
un'esperienza quindi quando andate nei
ristoranti non andate solo per nutrirli
andate per vivere un'esperienza e
chiedete quello a chi sta dall'altra
parte io voglio fai tu fammi stare bene
voglio in un'esperienza questo è davvero
molto importante per voi ma anche per
noi e quindi cosa posso dirvi
credete nella cucina non solo come un
luogo dove appunto andare a cibarvi a
nutrirvi ma credete nella cucina come
cultura dell'italia perché noi abbiamo
una quantità di prodotti straordinari
nel mondo e se noi crediamo in quello
facciamo anche una rivoluzione economica
perché l'italia non è fatta per le
grandi fabbriche lo vediamo siamo lunghi
stretti le vie di comunicazione
e poi ormai nessuno più voglia di avere
una fabbrica che inquina vicino
probabilmente dobbiamo ritornare a fare
quello che abbiamo sempre fatto
benissimo in una cultura legata alla
gastronomia quindi dell'allevamento
quindi della pesca della pastorizia e
tanti ragazzi stanno tornando ai più di
quello che voi pensiate tantissimi a
volte vengono dall'estero per venire a
coltivare ed allevare da noi quindi vi
dico vivete il ristorante come un luogo
di cultura e siate felici e ditelo
quando mangiate bene quando vivete
un'emozione vera ditelo a chi sta di
fronte a voi perché godrà della vostra
felicità grazie ea leger
[Applauso]
[Musica]